-We were talking, during the
break, about remote learning
I got a 2- and a 4-year-old.
There is not a lot of it.
How is your 10-year-old doin
and are you helpful?
-Yeah, I mean, well,
here's what's terrifying
is she does remote learning,
so there's social studies,
there's English, there's art
And I'm always happy to hop in
and help her out.
And then when I see her coming
at me with her math sheets
I cringe because it's become
very clear
to both me and my wife
that our math knowledge
kind of topped out
in third grade
and hers is at
a fourth-grade level.
And there are literally --
I just have this thing
we downloaded called the Tin
Math Pack, and I'm trying --
I downloaded my own so I can d
it and then check her answers.
And I realize I don't know
how to do these new things
where it's called the bar method
for solving --
-Oh, no.
-I'm like, "I don't know how
this works."
And I'm going to get this wrong.
So I'm terrified that she'
going to come to me and go
"Can we go over this?"
I'm like, "I kind of
don't know what this" --
So I'm trying to
find YouTube videos.
-Yeah. I can't believe
how ignorant I am
that it never occurred to me
that there would be
a different way to teach peopl
the same stuff.
-Exact-- Well, apparently
that happened in the '60s
with new math,
but now the new math
that you and I grew up on
is old.
And there's something
called Singapore math
and there's something called
the bar method.
There's all these new methods.
I have no idea.
I don't know what to do.
-Oh, it's good to look ahead and
realize that's the frustration
that's coming down the pik
for me.
-It is coming, so get ready.
It's -- Oh, boy.
-I just want to say that you
hosted the Webby Awards
on Tuesday night.
I actually hosted that sho
a few years ago.
It's a ton of fun.
I, of course, did it live
when there was an audience
I think this is a thing a lot of
comedians are figuring out
How will this sort of
virtual entertainment work
Did you still have
a good time doing it?
-I had a good time recording it.
I mean, I hosted it
three times live.
-Gotcha.
-And you're right.
It is such a fun show.
It's really goofy.
It doesn't take itself
seriously.
And now, I'm scrambling
to catch up
with the technology
that's needed.
So there was a lot of things
There was a lot of texts
that needed to be read.
And I had to keep looking,
because I don't have --
I couldn't figure out
teleprompter technology
and proper lighting,
so I did the best job I could.
But I hope that historically
people will look at
the 2020 Webbys and go,
"This has a real
post-apocalyptic wasteland fee
to it."
Which might be a good historical
document for this is the time.
But I hope
if they ever ask me again
I will be a little
more up to speed with --
Because it especially
celebrates people
that are doing amazing thing
on the Web.
So a lot of it just
looked great.
And then they cut back to
Grandpa Oswalt.
"Is it on? I don't see?
Hello? Okay."
Like, it's just this weird
multi-generational thing.
You know?
-Yeah.
-A little weird.
-It's so true that so much wor
is going to be timestamped
in a way that will make it ver
clear when anybody looks back,
"Oh, that?
That was during that?"
-I have gone down
the saddest rabbit hole
where I will go
online to YouTube.
I don't know
if you're doing this, too.
People have posted videos
for years now
of huge, like, summer
blockbusters, the big moments,
and they will
record the audience
cheering for big moments.
-Oh, wow.
-A guy recorded opening night of
"Avengers: Endgame,"
all the big moments
when Captain America
goes "Avengers, assemble" or
when he picks up Thor's hammer
all those where the crowd is
just "Yeah!" like, freaking out,
and I'm watching all of thes
with this sad, like --
remember people just out
cheering for stuff.
I'm watching all this --
and I used to despise
people in movies filming things.
Now I thank God that people were
there recording the audience
because it's like this age
that's gone now.
-Yeah.
-And now there's like
whole videos put together,
like best audience reactions o
"Deadpool,"
best audience reactions of -
and I'm just watching all this
stuff, and it's amazing.
-What a funny thing
that you're right, that I thin
we all wanted the moviegoing
experience to completely make us
forget that we were
watching it with other people.
And now, of course, that's
the thing you miss the most.
Patton, it's always
so lovely to talk to you.
Stay safe and healthy,
and we'll see you soon,
hopefully in person.
-Yes, hopefully in person,
alright, man, be safe.